On October 1st ,1949, Mao Zedong
proclaimed that the Chinese people have
stood up to become a "peace-" and "freedom-loving" nation. 70 years, later has this
dream been realized? A look at China
today clearly shows it has not. Certainly
China is not a freedom-loving nation. Its
mass crackdown on political dissidents
and oppression of religious minorities
demonstrates its continued
authoritarianism. It is also not a
peace-loving nation. It is building up
its military to challenge the United
States and coerce US allies in Asia.
However, in the last 40 years, China has
achieved much. China's economic growth
has lifted millions out of poverty and
propelled it into one of the world's
largest economies. China has also made
great strides in technology advancement.
Unfortunately, what has not accompanied
this growth is greater political freedom.
I hope that in the next 70 years the
Chinese people
will eventually enjoy the promises made
to them in 1949. Do you think the Chinese
Do you think the Chinese people will really stand up to the Chinese Communist Party? Let us know in
our poll. Also, let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI.